what breaking news Sarah Jane Sue gray
has been appointed Chief of Staff to Kia
stamina now that appointment will be
subject to the acaba process the process
and government to ensure that role that
senior civil servants and politicians uh
take on it doesn't prove it doesn't
allow conflicts of interest of course
Sue gray was a name we heard endlessly
last year because she was the author of
that report into lockdown breaking
parties at the heart of government in
Downing Street and in the cabinet office
previously she held a role in charge of
propriety and ethics within the cabinet
office and an investigation into
ministerial misbehavior certainly played
a role in the ending of some cabinet
careers now some people argue especially
those on the conservative side this
poses a ton of ethical questions because
this is not just a civil servant moving
into a political role but a civil
servant who has been passing judgment on
senior politicians some would argue
judgment that has led to the ends of
their careers look what happened to
Boris Johnson a few months after Sue
Gray's report came out certainly for
kierstama I suppose he would argue and
his team would argue that this is a coup
they want to show that they are
preparing for government that they are
ready for government and there has been
a vacancy in his chief of staff role
over the past few weeks because the
previous occupant was dismissed not very
popular with the shadow cabinet and
kirstama wanted we're told somebody with
top level government experience somebody
who knows what life is like at number 10
because ultimately he realizes he and
his team uh he and much of his team have
not served in numbers that have not
served in government they need somebody
with that experience to ensure they
potentially hit the ground running if
they win the next election and don't do
what Tony Blair argued he did which was
in the early years be a bit too cautious
castle and not get through key public
sector reform so sue gray has been
appointed to this role we understand
today she's resigning from her job in
the cabin office but as I say Sarah Jane
this appointment is subject to the acaba
process it doesn't need to be approved
effectively by Lord pickles Eric pickles
and his uh body within government so I
don't think she'll be taking that role
immediately